ASSEMBLY MEMBER BRO NOTICES THE
ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANT AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. HURRY ARAMBULA.
BARKING HAN. BERMAN BIGELOW.
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH. BONTA
BRO BURKE CALDERON CARRILLO
CERVANTES CHAU CHEN DAVID CHIU
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER
CUNNINGHAM DALY DALY DEEP.
EGGMAN FLORA FONG FRAZIER
FRIEDMAN GABRIEL GALLAGHER
CRISTINA GARCIA EDUARDO GARCIA
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ GRAY
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN JONES
SAWYER KALRA KAMLAGER KILEY
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON LOW
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES
MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ MULLIN
MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH. STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
RIGHT.
MEMBERS
A QUORUM IS PRESENT WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE REAR
CHAMBER AND IN THE GALLERY.
PLEASE STAND FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN
REVEREND PATTY OR STAFF MEMBER
NISHA. PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF REFLECTION. IS OFTEN
THAT IS SHARED OVER CITY WILL
BRING PEOPLE TOGETHER. WHEN THE
ADVERSITY IS A PANDEMIC THEM
BORDERS DISSOLVE AND WE ARE
MADE TO SEE AGAIN THE BE ON ALL
THE BOAT BOUNDARIES THAT ME
SEPARATE US. WE ARE ALL AND
PART OF ONE VANITY. WHEN I WAS
THERE MY EYES OPEN WE SEE AGAIN
THE NO LIFE CAN EXIST IN A
VACUUM. ALL HUMANITY IS
INTERCONNECTED. WE ARE ALL ONE
IN THE FABRIC OF LIFE. AS WE
MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER THROUGH
THIS CRISIS. LET US NURTURE OUR
AWARENESS OF TRULY BEING ONE
HUMANITY. FOR KINDNESS FLOWS
MAR AWARENESS OF BEING ON. NOW
MORE AMENABLE TO WITH KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING AND JOIN US FOR THE
FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN US
SMITH AS SHE LEAVES US IN THE
PLEDGE. PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SALUTING OUR NATION'S FLAG. I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. WHICH IS.
WHEN IT IS A LITTLE YES WRONG
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
MOVING TO READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER SACRAMENTO WEDNESDAY
MARCH FOURTH TWENTY MISTER
BONTA MOVES IN MISTER FLORES
SECONDS THAT THE READING OF THE
PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL BE
DISPENSED WITH. PRESENTATIONS
OF PETITIONS THERE ARE
INTRODUCTION AND REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS
OF COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED
ADOPTED MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR THERE ARE NONE
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE THERE
ARE. NONE. MOVING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS TODAY'S
ABSENCES FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS
NECESSARY IN CUNNINGHAM AND
DOLLY. FOR ILLNESSES ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON GABRIEL QUIRK
IN CHIANG AND FOR MATERNITY
LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AROUND
DAYS. RESTAURANT YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR MOTIONS.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE FORTY FIVE POINT FIVE TO
ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBERS COOLEY
AND GIPSON TO SPEAK ON AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY TODAY
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER MOVING TO GUEST
INTRODUCTION. MR REVERSE YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUEST
INTRODUCTIONS. SPEAKER AND SO
THIS MORNING IT'S MY PLEASURE
TO INTRODUCE- HERE WITH US THIS
MORNING PARTICIPANTS FROM A
PROGRAM LEADERSHIP MORGAN HILL
THERE ARE RIGHT AND- AND UNLIKE
OTHER SORTS LEISURE PROGRAMS
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE LEADERSHIP
MORGAN HILL THE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. THEIR GOAL IS TO
DEVELOP CURRENT AND FUTURE
LEADERS WITHIN THE LOCAL AND
REGIONAL- YOUR CITIES AND
COUNTIES IN SO THIS PROGRAM IS
DESIGNED TO PROVIDE
PARTICIPANTS WITH A GREATER
UNDERSTANDING OF LOCAL- THE
POLITICAL ECONOMIC AND
GOVERNMENT NON GOVERNMENT
STRUCTURES WITHIN OUR LOCAL AND
REGIONAL- AREAS. AND THE LARGER
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SO IT'S AN
HONOR TO HAVE THIS LOCAL
RESIDENTS WITH US THIS MORNING
TO LEARN ABOUT OUR GOVERNMENT
WORK WE DO HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE AND I HOPE THAT
THEY WILL BE TO LEAVE AND
THEMSELVES SUNDAY ENGAGE IN
PUBLIC SO PLEASE IT WELCOME ME
OR JOIN WALKING IN THAT HERE
WITH US THIS MORNING. THANK YOU
MISTER INVEST IN WELCOME.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE THE SECOND READING FILE
FILE ITEMS ONE THROUGH THREE
THE CLERK WILL READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHT
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE WITH
AMENDMENTS IN NINETEEN THIRTY
SIX WITH AMENDMENTS ALL BILLS
HAVE BEEN DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. ON
RECONSIDERATION HIGHLIGHTED
FOUR THROUGH SIX PM SUN
RECONSIDERATION OUR CONTINUED.
MOVING TO. THE ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING FILE ITEM SEVEN THROUGH
FORTY SEVEN WILL BE PASSED AND-
RETAINS. SENATE THIRD READING
FILE ITEMS FORTY THREE FORTY
NINE ALSO PASSED THE ROUTINES
MOVING. MOVING TO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR DO ANY MEMBERS WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SEEING AND HEARING ON
THE CLERK WILL READ THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE EIGHTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REYES RELATIVE
TO INTERFAITH AWARENESS WEEK.
THE CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE ON
THE COUNTER. ALL MEMBERS VOTED
TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTED TO THEIR TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTED IS THERE TO VOTE.
MEMBERS ONLY DESIRE TO VOTE
CLERK WILL CLOSE THE ROLLING
TALLY THOSE. I SIXTY FIVE NO
ZERO ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THIRTY WILL READ THAT MEETING I
AM SENDING THANK CALENDAR HOUSE
RESOLUTION EIGHTY SIX I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO. MOVING TO MEMBERS.
I KNOW IT'S THURSDAY BUT WE
WILL NOT BE LIFTING THE CALL ON
AN ADJOURNMENT IN MEMORY WE
HAVE SOMEONE IN YOUR OWN HOUSE
WHO HAS PASSED AWAY WE WILL BE
JOINING THEIR MEMORY THE ONLY
TO ANNOUNCEMENTS MANAGER ANY
MEMORY BUT WE WILL NOT BE
LIFTING THE CALL MOVING TO
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBER PLEASE I
NEED KING ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY. IT WILL BE
HAVING OUR- CAKES. IS OFFICE.
IS IT ALL MR LACKEY IS IT YOUR
BIRTHDAY TODAY. IS IT YOUR
BIRTHDAY TODAY AS WELL MISTER
LACKEY WHAT HAPPY BIRTHDAY.
THERE REALLY CUPCAKES IN ROOM
FORTY TWO FOURTEEN UPON A
GERMAN IN SESSION WILL SING
HAPPY BIRTHDAY AND CELEBRATE.
THIS SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY MARCH THIRTEENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION AND NO CHECK
IN SESSION MONDAY MARCH THE
SIXTEENTH FLOOR SESSION TO ONE
PM. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
NOT LIFT THE CALL. PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF THE FLOOR.
BUT I HAD.
MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS FOR GERMAN TO MEMORY
AND GIVE YOUR IS RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS. WE'RE
GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION TO
SPEAK ON AN ADJOURNMENT IN
MEMORY. MR COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN IN
MEMORY. COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY
TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF RICHARD
LEE- MATH FRICKA. A DEPUTY A IN
THE OFFICE ALLEGED COUNCIL
BUREAU. AND RICHARD- PASSED
AWAY AT THE AGE OF THIRTY FOUR
ON MARCH FIFTH AFTER A LENGTHY
BATTLE WITH CANCER. WHICH
SERVER MORE JUST IN LIFE LIFE
IS FLEETING. TO PASS WITH
THIRTY FOUR IS A GREAT LOSS FOR
HIM HIS HUSBAND HIS FAMILY. AND
THEN THERE HAVE BEEN A PART OF
LOS HAVE COUNTS YOU KNOW WE
COME HERE ON THIS FLOOR WE
PARTICIPATED IN ACT ONE OF LOS.
AND WE THINK ABOUT THIS
INSTITUTION AND ITS TRADITIONS.
THE LOWER OF THE ASSEMBLY THE
LORE OF THE SENATE. EARLY THE
LEGACY THE WORK OF THE SENATE
IS THAT ALL THOSE BLUE BOOKS
THAT WE WALK BY AS YOU WALK IN
AND OUT OF THE CHAMBERS EACH
DAY. IT IS THAT BODY OF LAW.
THAT WE ARE PARTICIPATING IN AN
ACTING. AND IT'S A VITAL PIECE
OF OUR LOWER BECAUSE OF COURSE
THAT IS WHAT PROVIDES FOR
CALIFORNIA AMERICAN SOCIETY. A
SOCIETY WITH FOUNDATIONS. THAT
THERE'S ACTUALLY A STRUCTURE TO
HOW WE- LIVE CONDUCT OURSELVES.
IMAGINE THE FUTURE. ALL OF
THESE THINGS ARE RISE TO THE
LOSS OF RICHARD LEE AMERICA.
BECAUSE HE WORKS ALLEGED
COUNCIL WAS VERY MUCH A PART OF
THAT HE SPENT HIS EARLIEST
YEARS IN PITTSBURGH. FOR HIS
FAMILY RELOCATED TO THOUSAND
OAKS HERE IN CALIFORNIA HE WENT
TO WESTLAKE HIGH SCHOOL IN
THOUSAND OAKS WENT ON TO ATTEND
NEW YORK UNIVERSITY. EARNING
HIS BACHELOR'S DEGREE IN
POLITICAL SCIENCE. HE FIRST
WORKED TODAY OUR SELECTION
COUNCIL AS AN INTERN. BACK IN
TWENTY TWELVE. HE RETURNED THE
OFFICES THE DEPUTY AND TWENTY
THIRTEEN. AND HE LEARNED HIS
EARNED HIS LAW DEGREE FOR THE
WESTERN SCHOOL OF LAW IN SAN
DIEGO. SO A GREAT BREADTH OF
EXPOSURE IN OUR OWN STATE.
DURING WHAT DURING HIS TIME IN
LOS HAVE COUNCIL HE BEGAN AS A
DRAFTSMAN. ADD INTO THAT BODY
OF LAW THE FORMS ARE SOCIETIES
FOUNDATIONS. HE WORKED IN
THERE'S A PUBLIC HEALTH
CRIMINAL LAW TRANSPORTATION.
MORE RECENTLY FOR FOUR YEARS HE
DEVOTED HIMSELF TO REFLECT UPON
THE LAW. IN RESPONSE TO
QUESTIONS FROM LAWMAKERS
DRAFTING LEGAL OPINIONS TO
WHATEVER ISSUES WERE BROUGHT TO
LEDGE COUNCIL TO BE ILLUMINATED
BY THIS BODY OF LAW THAT WE ALL
SUPERINTEND HE WOULD AFFECT
UPON THOSE QUESTIONS AND BRING
FORTH HIS INSIGHTS. SO HE IS
THE ONE WHO REALLY EXPLORED THE
FOUNDATION OF OUR SOCIETY SHED
LIGHT A CONTEMPORARY QUESTIONS
ARM. HE WAS A PERSON RESTORED
THEIR CHARACTER RICHARD LEE OF
AFRICA WELL REGARDED BY HIS
LIFE FOR HIS LEGAL ACKERMAN
WHICH OF COURSE. AS A LAWYER I
RESPECT AND WE ALL CELEBRATE
TODAY HIS WRY SENSE OF HUMOR
AND KIND HEART. HE HAD A
SPECIAL CAPACITY FOR LISTENING
WHICH WE KNOW THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO ACTUALLY HEAR WHAT
IS THE HEART OF THE ISSUE. THAT
SOMEONE'S TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
TO SHED LIGHT ON SO INVEST
YOURSELF IN ADDRESSING THE REAL
MATTER AT HAND. AND MAKING
OTHERS FEEL BETTER IN THE
CONDUCT OF THEIR WORK. HE LOVED
TRAVELING SPENDING TIME IS
BELOVED DOG BARRY. ASSEMBLY
JIGSAW PUZZLES WHICH MAY BE
REVEALING THE HOW HE COULD
ENTER IN THE LIFE OF THE
LEGISLATURE IN AND BE SORT HOME
SO MUCH OF OUR LIFE IS IT IT IS
CURIOUS AT TIMES IN ITS
COMPLEXITY AND CHALLENGE. AND
HE ENJOYED EATING DELICIOUS
FOODS ESPECIALLY HIS DAD'S
EXCEPTIONAL ITALIAN COOKIE. SO
I JUST WANT TO SAY RICHARD LIAM
AFRICA WILL BE SORELY MISSED BY
ALL WHO KNEW HIM. HE IS
SURVIVED BY A HUSBAND WILLIAM
MCRAE HIS FATHER RICHARD HIS
BROTHER CANDY AND A SISTER
BAGGY AND I JUST THANK YOU ALL
FOR. BEING A PART OF RICHARD'S
LIFE AND I REQUEST TO ADJOURN
HIS MEMORY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER COOLEY WE ARE ALL GREAT
FOR GRATEFUL TO HIS SERVICE TO
OUR BODY. MR GIVE SEND YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM SPEAKER MEMBERS TODAY ARE
RISE **** BODY TO ADJOURN THE
MEMORY. OF MR AMOS BROWN'S
SENIOR. THE GRANDFATHER OF THE
OF OUR- DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS CHAIR
CONSULTED MISTER- EMMANUEL HEY
ZEUS AND I UP NOW THANK MISTER
RIVAS- MISTER BROWN WAS A
RESIDENT OF MISTER REVERSES
DISTRICT. MISTER BROWN GREW UP
AND MAKE IN MISSISSIPPI. AND
WAS THE OLDEST OF TEN BROTHERS
AND SISTERS AS A BOY HE
WITNESSED THE OBSTRUCTION OF
THE ATTEMPTS TO OF STAGNATE THE
PROGRESS OF THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. BUT HE DIDN'T LET
THAT PREVAIL HE EXT OUT LIST. A
LIFETIME OF WORK IN HIS
COMMUNITY WHEN HE RETURNED TO
THE KOREAN WAR HE CONTINUED TO
WORK HARD AT THE CONSTRUCTION
SITE WITH HIS UNCLE BUT ALSO
HUSTLED AS A TOP. OF INSURANCE
AGENT BY NIGHT. HE MET AND
MARRIED THE LOVE OF HIS LIFE
HIS BEAUTIFUL WIFE JOSEPHINE.
ESTRADA WHO GAVE HIM SIX
BEAUTIFUL SHIP BIRACIAL
CHILDREN. MISTER BROWN USE ALL
OF HIS EXPERIENCE. HIS OLD
SCHOOL WORK ETHICS AND FAITH
AND RESILIENCE AND HE FOCUSED
ON BUILDING A LEGACY AND GORE
IN THE COR COMMUNITY HE WAS
ALSO KNOWN FOR IN THE
COMMUNITY BY NAME OF FAMOUS
AMOS FOR PROVIDING JOBS AND
HOLDS TO MANY. HE WAS THE LIFE
OF THE PARTY AND NEVER MISS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO DANCE OR BE
AROUND HIS GRANDCHILDREN WHOM
LOVE WHO THEY LOVED VERY DEARLY
AND HE AND HE LOVES THEM. HE
LIVED EVERY SINGLE MOMENT WITH
HIS HEART AND SOUL. HE ALSO
COINED AND CONTINUE TO PAY FOR
WITH THE PHRASE EARLY TO BED
EARLY TO RISE MAKE A YOUNG MAN
HEALTHY WEALTHY AND WISE THAT'S
WOOD MISTER AMOS BROWN SENIOR
SAID. MEMBERS OF AS WE REFLECT
ON AIM IS BROWN'S LIFE I'M ROOF
MINDED OF A LEADER IN THE BIBLE
BY THE NAME OF MOSES MOSES HAD
A JOSHUA AND I SUBMIT TO YOU
HIS GRANDSON WHO WORKS AS A
CONSULTANT TO THE DEMOCRATIC
CAUCUS IS THAT JOSHUA. AND WHEN
MOSES HAD TO LEAVE MOSES
PREPARE JOSHUA TO TAKE ON THE
MANTLE MOSES HAD TO LEAVE NICE
TO MEET YOU TODAY THAT MR AMOS
BROWN HAD TO LEAVE SO. HIS SON
HIS GRANDSON- E. J. EMMANUEL
ZOOS- AGUAYO LEAVE. ASK THE
WEIRD IN MAY. MR AIM IS
BROWNSEA. THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE
NAMES TO THE DEATH TO BE
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
REQUEST RETURN IN MEMORY WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND PRINTED IN
THE JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED TO
RETAIN ALL MOTIONS SHALL BE
CONTINUED SEEING AND HEARING NO
FURTHER BUSINESS I'M READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MR BONTA MOVES AND MISS WALDRON
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY MARCH
SIXTEENTH AT ONE PM. QUORUM
CALL IS LIFTED.